a couple tips I have for being the most
productive version of yourself since we
all wish we could get more done one is
to really figure out when you do your
best work I think there's a classic
expectation that we all you know start
work at 9:00 and work at 5:00 that's the
kind of way that it's always been done
but for many people that's not actually
the case I know people who are
incredibly productive in the morning and
then have a slump in the afternoons for
me I actually get really productive late
at night I can just sit on the couch
with my laptop and just crank through
things that would be challenging for me
to do at other times so my first tip is
figure out when you personally are
productive and then protect that time
that actually leads really well into the
second tip which is to put up barriers
so for example it's really hard when
you're sitting at your desk or if you're
somewhere where people have easy access
to you to not get interrupted somebody
has just one question or there's a fire
that suddenly needs to be put out and
you are the only one who can do it and
so what I really need to be my most
productive self I will often physically
put up barriers so this can mean coming
into work an hour late and just taking
that time at home to really focus it can
mean actually booking a conference room
not for a call but because I just need
to be in the zone for one of my
co-founders you know she will actually
sometimes have a headphones that she'll
put on whether or not she's listening to
music because it actually lets her
really zero in on time to just
completely focus and then my third tip
for being your most productive self is
to delegate like your job depends on it
which in effect it does I think that
many of us suffer from what I might call
Superman syndrome which is this idea
that we have to do everything ourselves
but businesses are built up so that you
can delegate you can share work figure
out what is it that's on your plate that
potentially should be taken care of by
somebody else on your team or another
team depending on your workplace it can
be a really useful opportunity to go to
your boss and have a conversation about
whether your priorities are the right
ones and whether there's anything you
should you could shift off your plate so
that you can focus more deeply on
something else at the end of the day
you've got to figure out what works for
you put up those barriers and delegate
so you can really get the absolute most
important work done